foreign
[Applause]
it's been two years since four neo-nazis
invaded my family's lake house and
murdered my father
15 now I've run away from three foster
homes
this is Elena Khan I've lived with her
for the past year
we call themselves The nobleman and they
may be coming here to Fillmore whether
or not the noblemen decide to make an
appearance at the Town Hall on Wednesday
only time will tell so are you going to
see this you're just gonna stand there
right this war
finally
did that on purpose
Diego
saving our country and stopping the
trees in one vengeful Mission at a time
to Freedom free freedom
[Music]
who is it
it's Becky
you took my dog
[Music]
should go to the cops I got enough
Weaponry in my barn to start an
Insurrection at Town Hall tomorrow
oh
[Music]
it was fun while it lasted that's not
over yet